It really is almost everything. Infrastructure is just about everything that makes civilization physically possible. Roads, bridges, water supply, sewage removal, dams, and so forth. The physical part of civilization is the infrastructure. That's Henry Petrosky. Well, my name is Henry Petrosky. I'm a professor of civil engineering and history at Duke University. He's written a number of books about catastrophic failures in engineering and also one about the history of the toothpick, so he's one of us.
这几乎就是全部。基础设施可以说是让文明在物理层面上得以实现的一切。道路、桥梁、供水、污水处理、水坝等等。文明的物质部分就是基础设施。这是亨利·佩特罗斯基（Henry Petrosky）的话。我的名字叫亨利·佩特罗斯基。我是杜克大学土木工程和历史学教授。他写过许多关于工程灾难的书，还写过一本关于牙签历史的书，所以他可以说是我们圈子里的.
His most recent book is all about infrastructure. The name of the book is The Road Taken, the history and future of America's infrastructure. A couple weeks ago, I interviewed Dr. Petrosky about his book and the state of infrastructure in the US. The first of many things that I learned that shocked me was that the word infrastructure itself is actually kind of new to English. What we call infrastructure today used to be called public works and in America, public works was probably a familiar term up until the 1980s.
他最近的一本书就是关于基础设施的。这本书的名字叫《走过的路：美国基础设施的历史与未来》（The Road Taken）。几周前，我采访了佩特罗斯基博士，谈了谈他的书以及美国基础设施的现状。我学到的众多事情中，第一件让我感到震惊的是，“基础设施”这个词在英语中其实相当新。我们今天所说的基础设施以前被称为“公共工程”（public works），在美国，直到20世纪80年代，“公共工程”可能还是一个广为人知的词。
But public works became a term closely associated with what was called pork barrel, which was also considered a rather pejorative term, because it had to do with building things that were considered unnecessary or wasteful. Pork Barrel is government spending push forward by a Congressperson to solely benefit the people in their home district. It was associated with politics that was tipped for tat. You vote for my pork, I'll vote for yours. But the connection between public works and government corruption got even worse than
但“公共工程”这个词后来与所谓的“猪肉桶政治”（pork barrel）紧密相连，这也是一个相当贬义的词，因为它与建设被认为是不必要或浪费的项目有关。“猪肉桶政治”是指国会议员推动的政府开支，旨在单方面使其家乡选区的民众受益。它与一种“你来我往”的政治利益输送相关。你投票支持我的项目，我就投票支持你的。然而，公共工程与政府腐败之间的联系甚至变得更加恶劣
trading votes. It reached its peak in 1973. There was a major scandal that one of our vice presidents of the United States had to resign, Spiro Agnew, because he basically was taking money for road contracts in his home state of Maryland. So in the 1980s, when shrinking government was becoming all the rage and pork barrel in earmarks were our biggest enemy after the Soviets, of Maryland. So in the 1980s when shrinking government was becoming all the rage and pork barrel and earmarks were our biggest enemy after the Soviets of course. The term public works fell out of fashion. So infrastructure became a term that replaced public works generally. But the term was still so new that in the 1980s the Wall Street Journal put infrastructure within quotation marks.
超过了单纯的投票交易。它在1973年达到了顶峰。当时发生了一桩重大丑闻，美国时任副总统斯皮罗·阿格农（Spiro Agnew）被迫辞职，因为他基本上是在其家乡马里兰州的道路合同中收受贿赂。因此，在20世纪80年代，当精简政府成为普遍风潮，而“猪肉桶”和专项拨款成为继苏联之后我们最大的敌人时，马里兰州的丑闻当然也推波助澜。当然，“公共工程”这个词也开始过时。于是，“基础设施”一词普遍取代了“公共工程”。但这个词当时还太新，以至于在20世纪80年代，《华尔街日报》在提及基础设施时还要加上引号。
Since infrastructure is the physical part of civilization, it's hard to generalize which government body or private party is responsible for each individual part of it. So in our conversation, we tend to focus on the big one. Well, let's take roads. We tend to think of roads, especially highways, as one of the wonderful things that the federal government does. Well, that's pretty much wrong. Roads today in the United States are largely the responsibility of municipalities and
由于基础设施是文明的物质部分，很难概括究竟是哪个政府机构或私人实体负责其中的各个具体部分。因此在我们的对话中，我们往往把重点放在最大的一块上。好吧，我们来看看道路。我们倾向于认为道路，尤其是高速公路，是联邦政府所做的众多美妙事情之一。嗯，这基本上是错误的。如今美国的道路很大程度上是各市镇和
states. One of the reasons that it's complicated like this is that the federal government is not authorized by the Constitution to build roads or bridges or even fixing them up by itself. It has to go through the states. Article 1 section 8 of the U.S. Constitution states that the federal government can build post roads, meaning routes for the post office to operate effectively, but no other kinds of roads are specified. In fact, in 1817, when a bill was passed by Congress that approved the funding
各州的责任。之所以会如此复杂，原因之一在于美国宪法并未授权联邦政府自行修建道路、桥梁甚至对其进行维修。它必须通过各州来完成。美国宪法第一条第八款规定，联邦政府可以修建邮政道路，这意味着为邮局有效运营提供路线，但并未指定其他任何种类的道路。事实上，在1817年，国会通过了一项法案，批准提供资金
of internal improvements in the country like roads and canals, it was vetoed by then President James Madison because he felt it was unconstitutional. And he should know because he wrote the Constitution. The federal government can give awards to the states, it can give grants to the states or municipalities, but it can't do it itself. But what the feds can do is put a tax on gasoline to raise money for roads, which they then give to the states and cities. This has been the case since the Revenue Act of 1932, which was passed by Herbert Hoover who raised taxes on pretty much everything. Presently it's 18.4 cents per gallon, and that gives the federal government about $30 billion
用于国内的道路和运河等内部改善项目，但时任总统詹姆斯·麦迪逊（James Madison）行使了否决权，因为他认为这违宪。而且他最有发言权，因为宪法就是他写的。联邦政府可以向各州颁发奖励，可以向各州或市镇提供补助，但它不能亲自去做。不过联邦政府能做的是对汽油征税以筹集道路资金，然后将这笔资金分发给各州和城市。自1932年赫伯特·胡佛（Herbert Hoover）通过《1932年税收法案》以来一直如此，该法案几乎对所有东西都提高了税收。目前这一税率为每加仑18.4美分，这为联邦政府每年提供了约300亿美元
a year to distribute to the states, and that distribution, the federal government exercises some control and enables it to provide some standardization to the roads, which I consider a good thing. Me too. Because you don't really want to drive from one state to another and find that the roads are completely different. It was the federal government that brought all the states into unification with the colors of the lines on the roads. Yellow lines divide traffic going different ways, white dashes divide lanes going the same
的资金用于分发给各州。通过这种分发，联邦政府行使了一定程度的控制权，并能够为道路提供一些标准化，我认为这是一件好事。我也是。因为你肯定不想从一个州开到另一个州，却发现道路情况完全不同。正是联邦政府通过道路上的标线颜色将所有各州统一起来。黄线划分不同方向的车流，白色的虚线划分同方向的
way. Yellow lines divide traffic going different ways white dashes divide lanes going the same way the federal government making the money contingent on following a standard is what made that happen. But the thirty billion dollar federal highway trust fund which would be to increase the gasoline tax. It hasn't been increased since 1993, which is quite a while. Because the federal gas tax has been so stagnant, the states take it upon themselves to levier their own state gas taxes and fund their road projects that way. Increasing the federal gas tax is not popular, so politicians have trouble doing it. But even if they could, it isn't a great solution. Obviously, if you're going to depend upon the tax on gasoline
车道。黄线划分不同方向的车流，白色虚线划分同方向的车道，正是联邦政府将资金发放与遵循标准挂钩，才促成了这一结果。但是，拥有300亿美元资金的联邦公路信托基金本来应该通过提高汽油税来增加收入。自1993年以来，汽油税就再也没有提高过，这已经是很长一段时间了。由于联邦汽油税长期停滞不前，各州只得自行开征州级汽油税，并通过这种方式为道路项目筹集资金。提高联邦汽油税并不受欢迎，因此政客们很难做到这一点。但即使他们能做到，也不是一个绝佳的解决方案。很显然，如果你打算依赖
per gallon for replenishing the fund, then you have to project how many gallons of gasoline are going to be used. And whether that volume of consumption is going to be used and whether that volume of consumption is going to be steady or increased. And generally, we expect things like that to increase with time. Right now, people are driving more electric and hybrid vehicles than ever before. They still use the roads, but they spend less money at the gas pump. So, pre-as-owners may be
每加仑汽油的税收来补充基金，那么你就必须预测将要消耗多少加仑的汽油。以及这种消费量是否会保持稳定或增长。一般来说，我们期望这类事情会随时间增长。而现在，人们驾驶电动汽车和混合动力汽车的比例比以往任何时候都要高。他们仍然在使用道路，但在加油站花的钱却变少了。所以，环保汽车的主权所有者们可能在
saving the environment, but they are mooching off our roads. It is so hard to do the right thing. So now there's a notion to separate the collecting of taxes needed to maintain the road from the consumption of gasoline. Instead of taxing the fuel that's used, you tax the mileage that the vehicle travels on state roads regardless of whether it uses fuel or not. And this can be done in a variety of ways. At present, there are a number of pilot programs that are trying this out. There are pilot programs that involve self-reporting the number of miles you drive.
拯救环境，但他们却在白白蹭我们的路。做正确的事真是太难了。因此，现在有一种观念，即把维持道路所需的税收征收与汽油消耗剥离开来。不再对使用的燃料征税，而是对车辆在州立道路上行驶的里程征税，无论它是否使用燃料。这可以通过多种方式实现。目前，有许多试点项目正在尝试这种做法。有些试点项目涉及由驾驶员自行申报行驶里程数。
But the obvious solution is to have a GPS-based tracking device inside each car. And we'll see if that goes anywhere. Because if you're someone who gets freaked out about the constitutionality of the federal government building roads, I'm going to guess that you're not going to be too keen on the federal government installing a tracking device in your car to see how many miles you drive. I suspect it will take at least a decade
但显而易见的解决方案是在每辆车内安装一个基于GPS的追踪装置。至于这能否推行，我们拭目以待。因为如果你是对联邦政府修建道路的合宪性感到恐慌的人，我猜你绝不会乐意看到联邦政府在你的车里安装一个追踪装置来查看你开了多少英里。我猜这至少需要十年时间
to replace the gas tax entirely, but it will probably come. Infrastructure is all about choices. When a new bridge is proposed, there are countless discussions about whether the bridge should be purely functional and therefore presumably cheaper, or if it should be a signature piece of architecture that attracts international attention. There are cases to be made on either side. I'm a signature man myself. But even mundane features like roads involve
才能完全取代汽油税，但这一天可能会到来。基础设施完全取决于选择。当提出修建一笔新桥的建议时，会有无数的讨论：这座桥究竟应该纯粹讲求功能性从而推测上成本更低，还是应该成为吸引国际关注的标志性建筑。双方都有各自的理由。我本人是个“标志性建筑派”。但即使是像道路这样平凡的特征，也涉及
choices that reverberate for decades. Most roads today that aren't interstate roads are made of asphalt. One of asphalt's advantages, of course, is that it's seamless. There is a real pleasure in driving on a new, smooth, black asphalt road. Plus, asphalt can be laid down quickly, it's relatively cheap, and it's easy to patch and repair. The downside is, it's not especially durable. You actually have to patch and repair it quite a lot. Alternatively, you can build a much more durable concrete road, but concrete doesn't offer that smooth, seamless ride that asphalt does, because physics. With concrete, we need what are so-called expansion joints. It would appear to be cracks,
那些会产生数十年影响的选择。今天的大多数非州际公路都是用沥青铺成的。当然，沥青的优点之一是它是无缝的。在崭新、平滑、黑色的沥青路面上开车是一种真正的享受。此外，沥青铺设速度快，相对便宜，而且易于修补。缺点是它不是很耐用。实际上你必须进行相当多的修补。或者，你可以建造耐用得多的混凝土道路，但混凝土无法提供沥青那种平滑、无缝的驾驶体验，这是由物理学决定的。对于混凝土，我们需要所谓的伸缩缝。它看起来像是裂缝，
but what are really deliberate lines cut into the concrete to allow it to crack in a controlled way. The cracks are there so that the road doesn't break into pieces when the concrete contracts and expands due to big fluctuations in temperature. But the tires of a vehicle going over them make a noise and the vehicle feels it. When you're driving on a concrete road, it sounds like, Duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, and the ride is not as smooth or as quiet as it can be on well-laid asphalt. In addition, concrete roads are more expensive, they're more expensive to repair, and they take longer. But they aren't as prone to potholes and can last a lot longer than asphalt roads.
但实际上是为了让混凝土以受控方式开裂而在其上面刻意切割的线条。这些裂缝的存在是为了防止混凝土因剧烈温度波动而收缩和膨胀时导致道路碎成数块。但是车辆轮胎碾过它们时会发出声音，车上的人也能感觉到。当你在混凝土路上开车时，听起来就像是，哒、哒、哒、哒、哒、哒、哒、哒、哒，而且驾乘体验不如铺设良好的沥青路面那么平稳或安静。此外，混凝土道路更贵，维修成本也更高，耗时也更长。但它们不容易产生坑洼，而且比沥青道路的使用寿命长得多。
So decisions have to be made. Do we go with the cheaper, quicker, easier method and save money now, or go with a more expensive slower and less pleasing method at hope to save money on repairs and replacement costs over time? Since so many of these decisions are made in a political context by people who know that they are going to probably move on before the repaying has to be done, will generally opt for the lesser expensive choice, which means asphalt. Asphalt is simply cheaper than concrete, and therein is one of the main reasons that we have
所以必须做出抉择。我们是选择更便宜、更快、更简单的方法来省下眼前的钱，还是选择更昂贵、更慢、不那么让人满意的方法，并期望随着时间推移能节省维修和更换成本？由于许多这样的决策都是在政治背景下做出的，决策者们知道自己可能在必须进行重新铺路之前就已经离任了，所以他们通常会选择成本较低的选项，也就是沥青。沥青比混凝土便宜得多，这也是我们国家拥有
so much asphalt in this country. But there is a more radical choice. In Montpellier-Vermont, there is a road called Bliss Road, which was in a terrible state of disrepair for many years. Until finally, in 2009, the city decided just to unpave the road, turn it into a dirt and gravel road. And since then, 27 states have also unpaved some of their roads for the same reason. I wondered if this was a clever solution or just a demoralizing defeat. I've heard about that and it does seem like a pretty clever solution. It's probably not a very popular solution among the paving contractors, for example.
如此多沥青路面的主要原因之一。但还有一个更激进的选择。在佛蒙特州的蒙彼利埃，有一条名为布利斯路（Bliss Road）的道路，多年来一直处于严重失修的状态。直到2009年，该市终于决定干脆把这条路取消铺装，将其变成一条泥土和砂石路。从那以后，有27个州也出于同样的原因取消了一些道路的铺装。我当时在想，这究竟是一个巧妙的解决方案，还是一场令人沮丧的失败。我听说过这件事，这确实看起来是一个相当巧妙的解决方案。例如，对于铺路承包商来说，这可能不是一个很受欢迎的解决方案。
It would depend on the nature of this road. If this is a road that doesn't have a specially heavy traffic, not a lot of heavy truck traffic, it might work from an engineering point of view. When the Eastern span of the Bay Bridge was about to open in 2013, they set aside a day for pedestrians to walk the bridge. Much like people did in 1883 when the Brooklyn Bridge was opened, I was all set to bring my kids and celebrate this new, massive piece of infrastructure. But because of last minute repairs, the event
这取决于这条路的性质。如果这是一条没有特别沉重的交通量、没有大量重型卡车通行的道路，从工程学的角度来看，它可能是行得通的。当海湾大桥（Bay Bridge）东段即将于2013年开通时，他们专门腾出一天时间让行人步行过桥。就像人们在1883年布鲁克林大桥开通时所做的那样，我当时已经准备好带上我的孩子们，去庆祝这个崭新的、宏大的基础设施工程。但由于最后一刻的维修，该活动
was canceled, and the bridge opened to traffic with much less public involvement in the fanfare. And I really didn't get a sense that people were all that upset about it. We collectively just don't have the feeling that infrastructure warrants celebration or a sense of pride like we once did. I asked Dr. Prachoski, why he thought that is? Oh, I think we, the electorate, has gotten mentally lazy about the infrastructure like we have about a lot of things. We tend to focus on what's of immediate concern to us. We might worry more about our driveway than the highway that is nearby. I do think that celebratory events are important and that do help generate that pride and
被取消了，大桥在公众参与度和造势都少得多的情况下对交通开放了。而且我真的没有感觉到人们对此有多么沮丧。我们集体就是没有那种觉得基础设施值得庆祝或产生自豪感的氛围了，不像我们曾经那样。我问佩特罗斯基博士，他认为这是为什么？哦，我想我们这些选民对基础设施变得精神上懒惰了，就像我们对很多事情的态度一样。我们往往只关注那些与我们切身相关的事情。比起附近的公路，我们可能更担心自己家的车道。我确实认为庆祝活动很重要，它们确实有助于激发那种自豪感和
almost responsibility because everybody is a part of all this. Different things that we vote for and pay for in our taxes and fees, we're really part owner of all that stuff and we should worry about it as much as we do our our neighborhood. What do you think about the idea of reclaiming the term public works, you know, to reflect the fact that it is owned by all of us and that it is public? That's a good idea. I haven't given it a great deal of thought, but that would make it more explicit. It's for the public and by the public in a way. Infrastructure is such a, what is it, a Latinate word that makes it more abstract and removed. So, yeah, that's
几乎是责任感，因为每个人都是这一切的一部分。我们通过投票和在税费中支付来支持各种各样的事情，我们实际上是所有这些东西的共同所有者，我们应该像关心自己的社区一样关心它。你觉得重新启用“公共工程”这个词的想法怎么样？你知道的，这可以反映出它是我们所有人共同拥有且属于公众的事实。这主意不错。我之前没有深入思考过，但这会让它变得更明确。从某种意义上说，它是为了公众，并且由公众所有。“基础设施”这样一个词，是什么来着，一个源自拉丁语的词，让它显得更加抽象和疏离。所以，是的，这是
an interesting idea. Good. Well, I just thought it out. Oh good, I'm, well, excellent. I have a proposal to send out into the world. 99% invisible is Sam Greenspan to Lady Hall, Kurt Colstad, Terran Maza, Katie Mingle, Avery Truffleman, Cherifusef, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Oliver Assis for answering some questions about pavement I had on Twitter. We use music this week from the trifecta of 99PI All Stars.
一个有趣的观点。很好。嗯，我刚刚才想出来的。哦很好，我，嗯，太棒了。我有一个提案要向全世界发布。99%无形（99% Invisible）节目的制作团队有山姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、黛莉·霍尔（Delia Hall）、库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Colstad）、特兰·马扎（Terran Maza）、凯蒂·明格（Katie Mingle）、艾弗里·特拉夫曼（Avery Truffleman）、谢里夫·优素福（Cherif Youssef），以及我罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。特别感谢奥利弗·阿西斯（Oliver Assis）回答了我发在推特上关于路面的几个问题。本周我们使用了来自99PI全明星三部曲的音乐。
That's OK Akumi, Lollatone, and Melodium. By their music and make your life better, we'll have links on our website. We are a project of 91.7 KALW San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and talk about this show on Facebook and follow us all on Twitter and Instagram. Our Tumblr curates cool design stories from around the web, but the easiest way to listen to all the past episodes and read more cool stories about the design is to go to our website, it's 99pi.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那是OK Akumi、Lollatone和Melodium。听他们的音乐会让你的生活更美好，我们会在网站上提供链接。我们是旧金山KALW 91.7电台的项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心广播街（Radio Row）制作。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并讨论它，也可以在推特和Instagram上关注我们。我们的Tumblr精选了来自网络的美妙设计故事，但收听所有往期节目并阅读更多关于设计的精彩故事的最简单方法是访问我们的网站，网址是99pi.org。目前这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。